so your first talking point is we could
be heading for a great depression talk
about that and the significance
of what of what bitcoin's gonna play in
that
yeah man i'm i'm like i'm curious what
you think about that
before i start going do you do you think
we're at the precipice of some sort of
big systemic crisis here do you think
they're just going to print their way
out of it and we're going to
i think they're going to try to print
their way out of it i don't think the
government's ever going to get out of
debt
like never ever ever ever uh it's not
happened at the levels that they're
going at
um let me just grab the m1 money supply
chart because that's probably relevant
um i'm sure you already know what this
is but for the viewers that don't this
is worth just throwing up on the screen
too
so if you're not familiar this is this
is 2019 ending here
and then this is all the money that was
printed in 2020.
so you know what happened right there
when that parabolic
rise started yeah talk about that
so in 2019
i mean we're seeing the stock market
just continue to go up and up and up
over uh trump's presidency and you know
with you know lowering tax rates and and
printing money and stimulus and all that
stuff but really
presidents don't have much of an impact
on the stock market
it's really the the central bankers and
the federal reserve and the
and the manipulation of the interest
rates that controls the stock market
so when when 2019
um september 2019 um there was this
thing that happened
which was like a real big crack showed
up in the financial markets to show that
everything that did
that they did over the last 10 years to
try to paper over the 2008
uh subprime mortgage collapse didn't
work
so in 2008 the regulators globally
cr came together and created these basel
accords
which are kind of like a set of
regulations that that
are like stress tests for the for the
central banks and the systemically
important banks like the big huge banks
and these things are like you've got to
have a certain amount of reserves
backing the money in your depo in your
accounts for your customers
so much risk with your commercial
banking
um you're going to meet a certain amount
of uh
expected 30-day withdrawals for for
uh you know normal activities so that
the banks basically can't be too over
levered like they were in 2008 which
which ended up causing
the whole thing to melt down right
the banks if everybody hasn't watched
the big short obviously it's a great
sort of dramatic take on what happens
pretty much truly what happened
yeah that's on netflix too still i think
yeah it is
and and they in and they basically
discovered that there's this kind of
fraud happening on wall street where the
ratings agencies like standard and
poor's
were just taking fees from the big banks
to make these extremely toxic risky
derivatives products
that they would then go and sell to
other banks and to pension funds
and to other investors and they would
they would mix toxic assets with good
assets so they take like triple a rated
stuff like government bonds right you
think the us debt is
a triple a rated asset it's not going to
bankrupt you know but they would stack
that
in with toxic [ __ ] like subprime
mortgages
and bets derivative bets synthetic bets
on subprime mortgages
so it creates this toxic basket that
everybody thinks is
good and then they sell it to each other
and then
banks have this thing called the repo
market it's an overnight lending window
where banks can borrow money from each
other
and not just borrow money but these
derivative instruments so i'm trying not
to get too deep into it to confuse
people but
just say that these banks are gambling
with each other and they're they're
lending each other base money so this m2
money
or m1 money supply here there's layers
of money in the system there's m0
which is base layer money you think that
that's the seed of money it's real
dollars it's stuff that the federal
reserve and the treasury creates
and then banks can fractionally lend it
out
to each other and to people and then
take loans on it
and fractional reserve that up into the
m1 money supply
so that like a hundred dollars of base
money
a thousand dollars of m1 and m2 money
and go ahead so sorry i'm just going to
jump in here and just kind of like
uh distill it down a little bit because
i'm going to keep it at the basics level
um so when i look at this chart
i'm looking at the billions of dollars
that
have been printed and this is
you know where the cursor is right now
it's uh january 2020 so let's say the
start of 2020 says january 6 here
as i drag the cursor across here you can
see all the years we're at 2010
20 2005 2000 all the way down to 1980.
they have printed a ton of money
about a third it looks like because i
went from four thousand to seven
thousand
billions of dollars is what it says here
yeah it's trillions it's trillions of
dollars
yeah like this is insane like you cannot
fathom
what kind of effect this is going to
have on the marketplace the stock like
it doesn't look like it's had much of
you know like much of a
effect from the user's end like you know
you still go to the gas station and gas
pretty much
costs the same you want to buy a loaf of
bread is pretty much the same
everything's kind of like you know you
don't really notice it but the thing
that most people understand is that the
value like the purchasing
value of your dollar keeps going down
over time
because they keep making more money they
keep printing it out of thin air
which which is one of the problems that
um bitcoin solves because
there's a limited supply there's only
ever going to be 21 million of these
things
i heard somewhere that because one of
the
one of the things that i've heard people
protest is well what happens when they
run out of mining bitcoin
and i think somewhere i came across the
stat where they're saying that
um because of each having event every
four odd years or so
they're legitimately going to be mining
this stuff until
uh like 2150 or something like that
yeah there's not really a risk that
bitcoin's gonna run out of
like security the miners are big pretty
well paid security guards for the
bitcoin network and it's the biggest
like most secure network on the planet
has more computing power than the nsa
and the cia
and the government of china and the
america and google and facebook all put
together
there's more there's more decentralized
computing power securing bitcoin than
ever
anything else on the planet so that's a
really well
paid uh system of of compute power
and there's also transaction fees inside
of every bitcoin transaction
so there's kind of like a a mathematical
formula that that shows that the fees
are going to replace the block reward
probably in around 10 years or so
so we're not really going to have to
worry about it because the miners are
still going to want to
process bitcoin transactions because
they're they're not going to be paid
bitcoin from the
the block reward anymore but they're
gonna be paid bitcoin in every block
with fees from people like you and me
who are using bitcoin and paying fees to
the miners
right so satoshi created this uh this
this system of game theory incentives
with putting 50 bitcoins
bounties in every block when it was
launched because there was no fees no
one was
using it so there was no fees there so
he had to reward people somehow
so he created the way to issue the whole
supply over 100 years
via block rewards and then we got to the
point now where it's like the fourth
epoch of bitcoin where the having is
not for another three years and there's
6.25 bitcoin now being issued in every
block
that's enough to like incentivize it to
be the biggest
computing network on the planet and as
the fees as the price of bitcoin goes up
and as
millions and millions of more people
come onto the bitcoin network
the fees will eventually replace the
block reward and as as bitcoin price
goes up so do the fees
so that's why bitcoin like that's why
i'd say that in the next 20 years or so
most of the block reward bitcoins are
gonna be already issued
and then at that point it'll be fees
securing the network
more so than the block reward for the
next hundred years or whatever
that makes sense okay so let's go back
to that point of we could be heading for
the great depression
um so not charged man like what do you
think's gonna happen
and my view is the government's never
gonna get out of debt they're gonna keep
printing money i feel like that the
great depression should have happened
already
you feel like it's long overdue but it
never seems to come
right so what's your what's your
position on that
well like we're seeing a show up in that
chart that you just showed like
they don't really have many tools left
in 2008 they
they had the tool of printing money and
that's what they did they printed
four or five trillion dollars and did
the quantitative easing the bailouts of
wall street
and and all the big corporations that
were taking too much risk and and got
bailed out by the taxpayer
and then they kept this this overnight
uh lending
window open but they weren't using it
so they were trying to say we're not
doing quantitative easing anymore the
markets are healthy look the basil
the basal the basil three requirements
are getting put in the banks have stress
tests they're passing them
so then in in september 2019 right
before that
tick in the chart the banks stopped
lending to each other
and the and the interest rate shot up to
eight to ten percent
and while the prime rates like the the
central bank rate was like
point five percent and they tried to
raise the interest rate a little bit
because the only thing to stop
um to stop printing money what they have
to do is they have to raise the interest
rates because then they can
like when the rates go higher people
will borrow less like the banks will
borrow less and they'll do less
risky derivative stuff because it's
actually more expensive
to take bets but when the rates are low
it encourages a lot of a lot of like
risky stuff to happen in the markets and
2008 gave uh gave all the bankers
basically the permission to take as much
risk as they wanted because they knew
that when they blew up the system they
get bailed out
and so what did they do in 2019
when the rates went up a smidge like
0.25 percent they tried to raise them a
little tiny bit
the banks just started to blow up they
started to stop landing
thing that caused the whole credit
crunch in 2018 2008
so they quickly said like we're gonna
give you as much money as you want
okay the overnight window is open
anybody can take money and they started
printing hundreds of billions of dollars
of base money like the m0 money
that can then be fractionally reserved
into bill
trillions of dollars through lending and
through the the money multiplier
so it took a few months to see it but
then it's not just the federal reserve
printing money that caused that
parabolic rise
that's part of it but it's also the
federal reserve is
more like sinister like in the way that
they're just printing money directly
into the bank accounts through the
overnight
repo markets and it's continuing ongoing
quantitative easing
now what this does is like it doesn't
let banks fail it doesn't let companies
fail
it just lets them continue to do the
same risky toxic behavior that caused
the 2008 collapse
and caused the march crisis when when we
saw everything drop like crazy in march
it's because they they didn't actually
get to the point where they could
pass the stress tests so they tried they
had 10 years to get up like the proper
liquidity reserves and
proper risk management protocols and
everything and then when the date
came that they had to actually put them
put them in in place
the whole thing fell apart and the they
had to print six trillion dollars to
bail everybody out
and they've suspended all requirements
for any systemically important bank
to have to meet any of the stress tests
so they don't need to even have
any percent reserves anymore so
literally the money in your bank
how long can it go on yeah you know
before the whole thing
collapses on itself well that's the
thing that that that's why like we could
be heading for great depression 2.0
because this does not make any sense
that this is
that money itself can just be printed
and inflated 25
like this and a parabolic like scale and
that it wouldn't cause some kind of
hyperinflation
like this is what happened in weimar
germany like they got
they got they got ahead of themselves
with the money printing
i think we're headed for that type of
level of hyperinflation like you see in
argentina or venezuela or lebanon or
something like that that happened over
the last few years
because we got a like there's there's a
few tools they have left
there's countries in the world where the
interest rates have actually gone
negative
and they've been toying with that in
europe and japan for a while so we could
see negative interest rates before we
see hyperinflation because they do have
a few tools left in the tool belt to
like
what we're seeing actually today with
all the stock shenanigans going on with
gamestop
those are some more tools that they have
they can actually like before we see
great depression or or uh like
hyperinflation
here's some things they can do they can
print another 10 trillion dollars
right like that's not going to cause
hyperinflation it's just going to
continue to allow them to kick the can
down the road for another few years
they can print 10 more trillion dollars
they can
they can lower interest rates into the
negative territory they can write off
half your student loan debt they can
give everybody um zero percent mortgages
to stimulate people to go buy and lower
the the um down payment requirements for
for a year say they can do some sort of
um
stimulus like they've been doing like
direct payments into people's bank
accounts
and like you know they could double
everybody's credit cards like if you've
got a ten thousand dollar limit on your
credit card they could say all
like this is like a jet debt jubilee
sort of thing where you everybody now
has an expert
go in and just take money from people
like just to you know
deny them access to their bank accounts
and liquidate balances right like we've
seen
was it cyprus or greece that did that
yeah
cyprus and greece did that cyprus greece
did a uh
the sovereign default on their debt and
all the
all the wealthy people that had like a
lot of money in banks just woke up to
half their money was just gone
so so like that's another that's one
that's a darker path we can go down
is like okay the the one thing they can
do to stop a global depression is to
switch to modern monetary theory
and like do a lot of debt forgiveness
and stimulation
but they're kind of already like to the
point where
the biggest metric you want to look for
that is the uh debt to gdp ratio
and and like we're at like 130 debt to
gdp
gdp to debt i'm sorry debt gdp
and that's the highest it's ever been in
history like
before the big difference between now
and before and other times during the
depression and world war ii
and things like that is that they had
they didn't use up any of these tools
yet like they didn't
do massive stimulus they didn't do
interest rates low
like back then the interest rates were
so high that they could actually taper
the interest rates down to like three
percent or something
and that would help the economy but now
they've used nearly everything in the
tool belt
and and they've jacked up the gd like
they've jacked up the debt rate so high
that it's 130 percent or something debt
to gdp
where that's that's bigger than it was
in during world war ii
so there's not even a really systemic
global
emergency happening like could you
imagine if there was a world war
breakout or something right now
they don't have the ability to lower the
interest rates much more at all they
don't have the ability to print
more money it's because then that would
put us to a 200 percent that the gdp
and that's just like it's already
uncharted territory we're at the
precipice right now
of some huge systemic shift and it's
going to either be a good thing or a bad
thing
yeah so i'm hoping it's the good thing
i'm hoping it's not great depression
but man it's uh well
okay so let's move on so i mean like
what he's basically saying there is if
you take all the ingredients of what's
going on in the economic world
today and you put it in a blender and
turn that thing on you're basically
going to pour yourself a nice [ __ ] shake
okay that's what we're dealing with
you